should be live and I'm just starting the
tournament weekly let's Arena me chess a
little bit disorganized here with my
windows but the framing looks ok
hopefully the audio is ok let me open
the chat
a lot of windows open
oh this is a decent player let's not
play the posi honey I'm gonna play
Spanish and just play some main line
just pay for
you
I don't usually play the Spanish but I
mean
it's a playable opening and this move
order is signifies you might want to
play it Marshall I'm going to play this
move t4 which is a bit more offbeat and
might cause them to think which is a
good thing
Audio is good thought you said 2 p.m. uh
yeah I decided to scream earlier nothing
nothing else to do and the weekly blitz
arena was starting now so we'll see
can I take on f7 here move
take take I think that's the move
the first time I ever encountered this
line was when a few years ago when I had
it from the black side and I got
completely crushed and I think was in
this move order where like white wins a
rook for two pieces but then there's
massive issues for black yeah because
after it take and then II five there's
Queen f3 coming and this rook gets hit
and it should just be over
you just fell into some open trap that
was nice back to tournaments
yeah I forget what my schedule said I
think it said like 2:00 to 3:00 p.m. so
I'll probably try and make it until 3
p.m. and do a 3-hour stream rather than
a two-hour stream can you read me with
the double question marker I can see
that comment and hello - mo Milano oh I
don't know if I replied to Momo Milano
send me a message on Twitch but I get
messages from so many different places
what did you say oh here's asking
about subbing
oh he mostly watches in the evening
interesting okay new opponents
let's mazurka try and get a quick lead
yeah if you want to stay if you want to
stay subscribe you have to sub every
month basically reset every month
oh is it quiet let me raise the volume I
think I accidentally was playing with
audio issues that should be a bit better
hopefully but let's try and focus
because I beserk this game
and I wanna have enough time to knock
flag night h5 is kind of a weird move
you
this night has to move back I want to
play a pawn h5 let's start with Knight
f3 there's many cases in the structure
yeah the night comes to e5 and at some
point I want to play h5 if he doesn't
play h5 himself
and if you takes on e5 I could take the
pawn or Bishop please 94 bits just move
let's take and then play h5
oh I forgot I'm allowing the Queen trade
which is probably okay take with Bishop
Bishop okay this is gonna get very
positional we trade everything
I feel like white should be slightly
better because I have the D file I have
pressure on the H file he castles some
prove the bishop also this pawn is
weaker than this pawn because I have
ideas with like rook h4 or Brooke d4
let's play Brooke d4 this just just
winds up on he's gonna try and drop my
bishop but then I'll play C 3 and life
is good
a5 c3 oh wow I forgot about c5
wait that's bad okay I I get three pawns
for the piece but I didn't want to allow
that well at least it makes things kind
of interesting let's play f3 I have to
make sure his Bishop is restricted as
much as possible I would like to play B
3 C 4 which I think will will happen
I'm winning the a southern pawn actually
wait take a seven Roque AIDS maybe I
don't want to take it okay let's play
Brooke a6 first problem if white takes a
seven years work a eight and he would
win something on the queenside I think
this is still okay though I might trade
a pair of rooks hello to Murr Kyle mr.
Kyle nine three three
Trey the pair when we trade the pair of
rooks and he can't easily infiltrate
also is he hanging a bishop not really
but I'll win the pond
oh he hangs a bishop okay I guess you
forgot about the vision oh that's nice
so now White's just up like two pawns
and I have plenty of time start pushing
past pawns
wait is it more Kyle or mr. Kyle
you said it almost right the first time
summer Kyle or Merc you'll I don't know
names are difficult
can people hear me doesn't like need to
be like in my face more yeah you can
hear me okay Stephen Stephen is Dedalus
these names are so difficult
I'm just gonna call him Stephen the
sound is so low turn up your volume uh
unless your volume is all the way up
then I don't know what to say and thanks
for the comment Merc I'll hear oak in
here okay that's good okay we're gonna
start pushing or continue to push the
pawns let's cut off this King first
maybe do this I made him in the center
somehow might be difficult
expecting rook c8 the play he for us
improve the King a little bit do you
accept all the challenges this is going
to be a blood stream I'm playing the
weekly blitz arena it's a three hour
tournament and yeah I'm not gonna be
doing any bowl of challenges today
unfortunately sound is fine okay so I
guess the one person who has a hard time
hearing me you might want to get some
hearing aids okay he's gonna win a
forever thought I'll play b6 and rugby
eight
22 seconds is plenty of time Brooke f7
check inconveniencing the king yeah I
mean lots of ways to win this camel
clutch sure is back I've been well I've
been busy I broke my microphone so
that's why I have a headset now but
things were good life is good this
position is pretty good I mean it would
be nice if he resigns okay that's nice
okay second place right behind King star
70 try and keep it up I miss anything
else
JC Jesse hf2 in the chat b5 oh yeah the
whole b5 c5 thing was pretty strong for
my opponent like he had chances there
okay so I'm probably gonna play this
chest to matters who just jumped ahead
of me yeah oh let's laughs buzzer can
let's play a London do I know this guy
national master from the US I probably
know him let's see some briefs talking
feet a rating Garcia maybe I don't know
him Garcia Eric the web guy yeah I saw
the clips from men he was talking about
me a lot I actually played him on his
own stream the other day and he'd be me
in a very brutal fashion it was painful
but he likes for some reason Ben likes
to say my name and crew 64 likes to say
my name I'm not sure why
wait am i playing this right yeah this
is still my prep I think is that Queen
b3 it's been a while since I've actually
looked at this line
somehow we're transposing into some
exchange Slav maybe feels like he might
be in his prep but visually this looks
completely fine for whites maybe I can
play 95 just exert some pressure I know
I have three attackers on the knight on
c6 I move like rook c8 usually hangs a7
pawn so there's some issues here already
if you take 75 I take back with pawn
this nights gonna be in this place maybe
he'll play Knight h5 attack the bishop
then Oh
my g8 interesting I could Castle
queenside East 6 actually looks like a
really fun move I don't know if it's
worth giving away a pawn let's play e6
it's a good let's move it gets it gets
initiative main idea is I want to bring
the Knight to e5 and if he ever takes
and there's there's more weaknesses to
exploit his Bishop is going to be stuck
so this is this is looking fun and this
is not like your typical London where
you just saw it I'm being very ambitious
here a 95 is a very hard move to stop
and then there's already like meeting
ideas it's just diagonal super weak I
don't know if I can exploit it
wait can I just play 95 anyway this is
like almost meat I don't care about this
Bishop I care about mating in on d7
oh this isn't winning I forgot about 906
take take okay I have to retreat there's
still this pin
it should be good somehow maybe h4 at
some points
you
as Kings tied down to the fighting the
bishop which is good
I'll play tricky move Bishop d4 the idea
is there might be tactics along the
diagonal for example White's threatening
to take on d7 and his knight would be
pinned
so I don't know if he can actually
survive this maybe I should have
considered Queen c2 there Queen c2 still
a candidate move
running mate in two so take take take
Queen c2 will probably play like Bishop
a chains
take
that looks like it has to be good
you
I have time here to calculate if I need
to
Bishop s AIDS
okay there has to be some horse wind
maybe you take on d7 then queen h7 and
his rooks actually trapped that's funny
she can't defend the rook that's nice
that was a feel-good game when we wrong
I think somehow he just got under
pressure like when this Bishop develops
to f5 especially in like in the London
opening but also like Queen's Gambit
openings there's a lot of a lot more
weaknesses on the Queen side that black
has to kind of watch out for and somehow
it worked out like these three moves
work very well in combination okay we're
moving on camel clutch er yada yada oh
no me pants King crusher King crusher is
always streaming his streams are so long
I don't know how he does it okay
squirrel Shepherd is here I've only been
streaming for 15 minutes about okay so
we're playing nigel Duke that's a
slightly less scary name than nigel
schwartz i'm gonna just play my normal
opening time on of usually the queen
goes to c7 Graydon is on a nine game
streak over the board Wow I was actually
on a nine game streak before the last
tournament I played in wait a nine game
no lost raker a nine game win streak
because there's a big difference a nine
game win streak is pretty impressive
wait what do I do here I think ninety
five right away because he's already
committed to f3
so the bishop doesn't to to develop and
I can just play b5 here chest Chopin
with the emotes I'm just gonna continue
developing I think the plan is to play
like d5 at some point like probably
right now but he's also allowing Knight
c4 let's do that I was getting rid of
this Bishop is a nice trade
I could take it right away okay and then
I'll play Bishop c5 this is looking nice
just build up some pressure I still at
some point at some point when I play d5
I could Castle first but there's no need
let's play d5 win streak nice it's nice
to just keep winning games like keep
gaining rating points take with Bishop
this is just such a nice position
h4 he wants to attack me I want to play
Queen a5 but I actually don't know
what's going on after b4 so I might just
lose a piece I could play e5 Knight f5
what to do critical moment maybe
before pawn sacrifice I'm just gonna
castle I want to get the rook to d8 I'm
not scared of what he's doing like that
my dark squares are not weak because I
have the dark squared bishop and next
time I just want to play e5 oh no me
pants one wonder why no consideration of
castle and ripped eh yeah that was the
most logical continuation wow he wants a
queen trade which I'm probably happy
with because I have the bishop here and
am i winning a piece with E 5 I think
that wins the piece because when he
takes on d5 I take back with rook and
there's a pin okay that's nice hero is
saying play me over the board yeah I
don't know if you guys will ever play
over the board just based on the
geographical difference yeah the last
win streak I had I went 10 games in a
row there's a tournament I went 5 out of
5 extra man I went 4 out of 4 extra meal
i won the first game but then lost in
round 2 to my win streak died which was
kind of sad but life goes on I'll play
g5 because the racast retreats and I'll
probably target the king they work see
aids
let's do this trade some rooks or not or
yes and maybe a whole hangnail on c1
maybe no oh what do I do
let's I want to push up on not too many
pawns can be pushed I'll just do this
you
you
ooh and then this that's a week's fare
okay I'm gonna fork him somehow
yeah like before Azumi maybe there's
meat where is the mate
I mean I could just play Knight c3 but I
want to meet him
wait That's not me okay I'll just take
the rook and maybe he'll resign
or maybe not
the fighting spirits
okay nice game yeah time I love is the
fun opening especially when white
doesn't know what to do first place 13
points oh the guy I just played is in
second place interesting pretty big
rating gap oh okay I don't know if I'm
missing much in the chat nigel Duke is
lucky not dodgy hello to Tamil ear I do
have a MacBook Pro I'm looking to
upgrade laptops I want a stronger
MacBook Pro uh I'll probably get a new
laptop next month okay so I'm playing a
decent player looks like higher rated
than me well fly another time on us if
he plays open Sicilian oh maybe he's
scared already thinking why is he
thinking let's move 3 d 3 hmm d3
signifies he might go for a Kings Indian
and I think the move to play here is e 5
and we treat this like a what do we call
it I don't even know what we call it I
play d5 immediately d5 take take I think
I can get away with that it feels weird
to like have wasted a tempo in e6 e5 and
then play d5 to open the center but if I
can reinforce the pawn especially the
Pauline e5 and Castle it should just be
more pleasant for black it's like over
vs. Marazzi binds dragon type position
I'm happy with this no draw I'm just
gonna decline the job usually the best
way to decline a draw is just to ignore
the draw offer but
have to make my point there h4
what is he doing he wants to attack me
on like both wings whoa
well I have Bishop g4 here he has bishop
a3 we Trey above 94 clingy one Queen I 5
that looks good
because when we trail off LightSquared
bishop s' his King side becomes a bit
weaker there's less pressure on this
diagonal night a3 might be a threat it
just looks Pleasant and his queen is
tied down to two pawns it's defending
this and this so if I play nine of three
here he goes kingi to I probably doesn't
lead to anything I guess we have to
trade oh but then he takes an attacks by
queen and night okay after retreats
mmm he's kind of untangling take take me
trade first and then bring the night
back I was not expecting him to take
with a spawn I have nine at five
Oh what to do okay I'll play 96 I want a
rook to come to the eights and maybe
play out five at some point let's play
might be four that's a nice square d3 is
really weak he has a bunch of Pauling
weaknesses here like d3 g3 h5 but
there's actually no way to the FNG 3 or
d3 so I'm winning at least a pawn and
the position should fall apart from here
more pawns hanging I could take on c4 I
could play Queen h3 I could play Knight
c2 so many good looking options start
with Queen h3 because I think it forces
92 and then I have night c2 that fall
apart really quickly for white
I think he should not have taken with
the ashkelon he should have taken with
the bishop in this position last
weakening jesse h f2 is asking what to
do in Paulsen after white plays 3 c3
after c3 I recommend to play d5 you play
d5 real quick for Jesse just opening
recommendation I enjoy this line d5 and
then I say take you take with Queen
because they don't have Knight c3 and it
transposes to some kind of a c3 Sicilian
like elephant variation so ok still in
first place expanding the lead I've
gained about like 40 points so before
this tournament I was below 2300
so maybe after this tournament I can
rate 2,400 we'll see
sorry it's a tamale the one person
challenging me I will not be accepting
challenges at the moment the best chance
you have to play me over the next like
two hours is to join this tournament
let's play you for this game I already
played a couple of London's I will take
opening recommendations - if anyone
wants me to play a specific opening let
me know I'm gonna play Ponzi on you this
game it's not a bad choice for blitz
very direct and he's thinking which is a
great sign on f6 we'll play d4 and we'll
play e5 yeah this is a very
straightforward opening like white gets
center gets more space
get some piece of activity I like to
throw in Queen b3 here forcing the
knight to move again and then I'll
recapture ah okay people are suggesting
openings and Alekhine could play an
alkine ball and cloud I don't think so
London or Ponzi Ani my two favorite
openings Q Venus convenient how do you
say that Cavanaugh's Sicilian you for c5
903 e 64 take I take oh queen b6
I don't think Queen b6 deserves 2x slams
but it's a playable move what do I do
here
because pawns are already weak I could
Castle let's castle
at some point I want to attack on the C
file but I'm trying to figure out like
how to develop your Bishop III Bishop f4
will play Bishop f4 if my bishop went to
e3 he would have annoying Knight see
four possibilities now the plan is just
to double up black doesn't have much to
do here there's very little active play
from the back side and he's gonna be
forced to like somehow defend this pawn
multiple times or just get triple pawns
which is actually interesting because if
I take and he takes he's gonna have a
nice square for the bishop on d5 I don't
know if I should allow and it's so
tempting to give your opponent triple
pawns but I'm going to do what I think
is best
going for b3 because I don't want his
Bishop to become a good piece and now
yeah his knight has to go away I guess
he could throw in Bishop before but he's
gonna have the same issues Wow more
opening suggestions Roy Lopez
caro-kann Wow I'm gonna have to scroll
up my next game and just pick an opening
chest Chopin is asking about something
you focus on what to take back with
maybe Bishop yeah let's take Bishop what
you're recommending it's Queen d6 candy
g3 systems
is there a spicy line I mean to be
honest I've really never knew what to do
against Queen d6 candy until the most
recent summer where I played an opponent
who exclusively played Queen d6 candy
and I had like a day to prepare and I
came up with like an interesting line
like a relatively rare line which just
seemed easy to play for white and the
computer approved I was like the
computer gave plus 0.6 so I can show it
but the basic premise of the line was to
play some wait let me focus again let's
to play something like I can't like
think of the other position while I'm
I'm playing this game chest chopping
remind me after this game finishes and
I'll be happy to show you let's triple
up what the Alekhine's gone I'm not up
anything but the position looks really
nice I just have to figure out where the
knight should go
I go to f3 could go to F 1 and then G 3
put it on G 3
and he can't really challenge the e-file
that's all but only open file which is
really nice this is he constantly has to
worry about stuff like rookie 7 and it's
hard for luck ticket counter play I
actually don't know what my night's
doing on g3p I chose the wrong square oh
wait he's challenging the e-file I
didn't think that was possible I guess
it is let's play h3 if he takes on e5
I'll take back with pond and the
position is going to transform play
Danish can okay uh let me stop reading
the chat there there there I think I can
play tricky six because I take with
Czech and if we trade Queens and these
weaknesses begin to show
hopefully
you
whoa he's defending I could take again
and then play the game that looks really
instructive actually this is probably
not the best moves like rookie seven
maybe it was better but this just looks
like a very instructive end game where
his bishops gonna be completely useless
he has no pawn breaks I'll slowly but
surely activate my king and there's some
long-term plans of like bringing the
knight to some better square for the
time being I'll place right out of my
knight on f4 where it's just a great
piece and this is just positional doom
for black like his bishop actually has
no way to like activate like it's
restrained in in black stone territory
and I think there's a very simple idea
here like walk the King this way and win
the a pawn and maybe he'll see it yeah
he sees it but there's still really no
hope for luck I think I'll put the rest
of the pawns on dark squares I'll bring
the knight to c5 and you could you could
very easily resign here
I guess yes Bishop h5 the best try ooh
this should h5 okay something has to
fall
wait that's kind of annoying I don't
want to pull a cramming okay I see an
idea I'm gonna do this he has to play
King d7 and I play f3 oops
f3 and then g4 and I'll have a past pot
looking nice and yeah he can't stop g5
such a nice night he's he in so long
like the bishop has no squares he can
only move the King back and forth but
that I'll keep pushing the pawn such a
feel-good position
yeah maybe trading rooks was actually
the objectively the best option so he's
sagging upon but it doesn't accomplish
much oh maybe I actually put him in
zoogs long if he plays king a7 I play c6
and it looks long okay lots of opening
recommendations of Bishop b5 I don't
move okay
GG I just realized I have not been
looking at any like alerts like stream
alerts um thank you for anyone who has
followed or donated I feel like I would
see donations or subscriptions but maybe
not no recent events oh thank you sleep
like a grandmaster for following and
glycol for following the two alerts so
far what's what I want to do Oh Chester
oppan yeah wait I'm still in first place
right
ah what'd I do well I'm tied for first
yeah let's go to analysis board wait
till I just break everything mmm that
looks okay okay just a quick easy line
if you're an e4 player I guess you you
basically have to have some prep against
between d6 Scandinavian it's a hard
opening to avoid unless you choose to
play Knight of three in this position
which is very reasonable for whites but
let's focus on this this and hopefully I
can remember my prep I actually forget
do we play d4 or nine f3 well I remember
is okay let's start with Knight f3 906
d4 so we follow main line and then at
some point black will play Bishop g4 I
guess a6 is a move to start with a6 the
idea that I had was to play Bishop e3
and like whenever you got a position
like this you play Queen d2 and you're
very happy to allow this trade where you
get the bishop here you're also prepared
to Castle queenside and you also prepare
to play Bishop f4 so that's honestly all
I know in this queen g6 Canadian so
flighty 9 f3 Bishop e3 Queen d2 and then
depending what black does maybe deviates
but I think the computer should support
this line of course there's all their
deviations like if c6 Bishop e3 Bishop
g4 Queen d2 it's a rare idea but I think
computers should like it yeah the whole
concept where like you you get out of
the pin these positions these positions
are completely fine with the G file I
hope
I didn't like get your hopes up too high
but that was this is my prep it's all I
know
so there you go if you have any specific
questions or any specific lines within
Queen d6
feel free to ask follow-up questions
beyond the mask is saying you need JB
here for this yeah the scandi experts
but I think John Bartholomew plays queen
d8 if I'm not mistaken which can't be a
good move there is a nice game Nakamura
versus Shaw you see if I can google that
Nakamura Shaw
Scandinavian I think it was this game
yeah it was this game where like
Nakamura just crushed Shaw with the
Queen d8 Scandinavian I know we're
getting off track let me go back to the
trim int I'll share this this link if
anyone wants to look oh I'm in third
place okay back to the tournaments oh
I'm playing the same guy again wait what
did I play against from last time
Oh as a London game let's play London
again we'll see where he deviates this
will be fun
oh he's flanking Xindian this time oh
and the phone's ringing um I don't want
to take it but let me write be right
back
I'm gonna continue the game I have a
thing for this wait it audio goes to
mutes
you
okay nevermind I think it was just a
spam call
oh he's cassings to h5 based on the
previous game i know that he doesn't he
doesn't know too much opening theory and
I take h5 is actually this is actually
much better for whites as far as I know
like even stockfish likes us for whites
I have to prove it I guess
hello 2x I sparks thanks for watching
like weights down the exchange but like
there's so much play so many resources
neither 395 looks very simple play queen
h2 hitting this night
you
you
but it's not over this is gonna take
work
it's Castle queenside I'm just going to
build that pressure maybe at some point
I'll play g4 and create some pin
or exploit the pimp on another idea is
to play queen g3 another idea is just 95
and then maybe g4 that looks nice I
think that's the go-to 595 g4
and this night's tied down to the pawn
which is nice
does my g5 work 95
that looks like a fork hitting this in
this
and if I win age seven that's got to be
good
I guess he is queen g6
now I move back
I just want upon screen doesn't
necessarily want to be on g6
oh wait no I'm attacking the rook so he
plays that
Queen g3 this is looking very nice
f3
yeah let's just play f3
and move right back
okay you staying alive but it's barely
I could play queen h3
g4 looks very enticing but I don't know
if it works is g4f take g4 and he
attacks the Queen so maybe I started
with like Queen h4 slightly safer Square
and then play g4
you
there's also ideas like Bishop there
should be 592 9f for
maybe I can start with and this was
actually almost Trappist Queen
that's a free Knights rights take take
I mean I'm just debating what to take
with take with Queen
wait okay everything's winning it let's
just take with Knights because it should
lead to a quicker quicker mate Oh is
there a weird audio buzzing or it's just
you hopefully there's not I should have
a noise suppression filter I can also
turn down the game just a little bit
there's a bun on my um on my headphone
cord I have no idea what it does but it
looks like this uh if anyone knows what
this does
I'm afraid to press it but anyway back
to tournaments that was a very smooth
win
he walked into what's just a bad line
for lack its forked a cage five line
normally when white plays h4 in those
positions black should respond with age
five so okay I'm in clear second or tied
four seconds right behind kid thirty
nine whose buzzer King a lot but at
least I'm keeping it clean
and haven't lost a game haven't desert
too much avoiding time trouble which is
always nice let's play what I want to
play let's play that there was a line
that I played yesterday it worked out
really nicely it's a reverse Grand Prix
where it's basically the same Grand Prix
setup that we all know and love but from
the backside I'll put the bishop on on
b4 where usually the intention is just
to trade off with dark-squared bishop
when the time is right and then go for
some attack later I might throw in a
five though he's doing some weird setup
because normally I would take but
because he can take with Knight
I think I can just move back and this is
like very very similar to Grand Prix or
it is a Grand Prix he's just reversed
95s have been annoying cuz he's
attacking c2 I probably have to take
you
and the goal is to still try and attack
on the the King side if he lets me be
four so if I take take take take
it should be six looks solid
sometimes what you have to do is like
minimize or neutralize a play on the
queenside and then focus on the kingside
so now it looks like I can focus on the
kingside the thematic move is at four I
don't know if it accomplishes anything
because he can take it might just lose a
pawn I think I'll start with this move
hitting the Knights and then depending
what he does like a move like rook e1 is
already a blunder because I can take and
then attack f2 so maybe it's not clear
what like what white does here maybe
Queen d1 or Queen e1 but then F 4 and
then Bishop g4 can come this is fun
chess Chapman asking about the marathon
that's a good question I don't think
I've ever played a marathon or like
seriously play the marathon tournament
but it would be cool to do like a
marathon stream wait so if I play off
for he takes I play Bishop g4 has to
play like rook e1 I take if he takes
with Bishop to I think that's working if
he doesn't take I play f3 I'm happy
I mean I could just do like a marathon
stream without the marathon tournaments
and just do like a 24-hour Blitzer
bullet brawl but I capable of staying up
that long that would be difficult maybe
when I reached something like 5,000
followers i'll do some huge celebration
i still need to figure out what to do
after reaching 1,000 followers which
happened like a week ago already so many
crazy things have been happening i've i
broke my microphone i've been traveling
so it's been hard to like get organized
anyway he plays rook e1 i think i can
just take and this pawn is untouchable
unless he wants to lose material in the
meantime i just want to play off three
or 93 or 96 and just torture him 24
hours of chess is bad for now british
short to 24 hours of anything is pretty
bad for health that's a lot of time I
could take the Knights and then take the
bishop or I could take the bishop and
then take his Queen then he takes my
queen then I take back oh I think this
is actually better wait what's better
yeah I take your first when you have two
ways of winning a piece you just have to
choose one and then not not use up all
your time
okay well trade Queens should be a
simple conversion f2 is still weak as
bishop is feel bad life is good
stephen is asking if I'm originally from
STL I went to school in st. Louis for
two years but I'm originally from
Chicago area
but st. Louis is kind of a second home
for me now I should be back in st. Louis
next month for US Championships as a as
a photographer and a Twitter master okay
what's the best way to win this maybe
just pawn storm try and get some kind of
checkmating attack
what's your school in Oakville I've
actually never heard of Oakville but st.
Louis it has like so many like small
like suburbs and like kind of small like
I don't know even what we call them like
municipalities but most of my time in
st. Louis was spent either in the
central west end near the just club or
in Webster near the University a my
trapping my rook hopefully not my rook
is okay it has one square
whoa d4 that's kind of annoying cuz my
rooks about trapped but I can play
Knight f3 and it's a fork and then I'll
win the pawn on d4 and I will have a
three again this is nice attacking this
Bishop f2 is still weak main-sequence
hosting me for five with five viewers
that's nice thank you main sequence
wait main see
winces another extremer who I met in
Australia not too long ago wondering
what time it is there it's gotta be like
some really unusual time okay I'm gonna
take on g4 where's my phone I don't know
where my phone is
I wanted to ask Syria what time it is in
Australia wait did I just plunder item I
wanted to take the bishop but I guess
we're just trading pawns
you
if he lets me I'll take his bishop next
move maybe Bishop c8 would have been
interesting he would win d7 but too late
now time to activate the king
you
you
what to do
you
you
time to resign maybe check the standings
in 4th place I need to not pause too
long between games because I think it's
easy to fall behind in the tournaments
oh but I'm back in clear first that's
nice and kid 39 lost a game um nice
kitchen at first I thought it said nice
kitten but well thank you Leedy that's a
new viewer let me rearrange my windows
so I see any alerts follows mostly
follows murmur 1 2 3 thanks for the
follow
Elessar of 6 2 4 4 - thanks for the
follow a love hike thanks for the follow
okay um my play over on e30 didn't I
just play him I forget when that game
was I guess not today
I'll play Knight of 6 I'm just gonna
play my my solid repertory for black
let's play d5 qgd Queens gambit declined
I should say where it should be 7 very
classical solid sort of slow chess I do
have a pet line here which we're not
going to go into maybe we could still go
into my pet moves to play a 6 Queen c2
Queen c2 feels like it should should be
inviting like c5 maybe wait did I just
lose the chat no the child is still
there trying to rearrange Windows here
we go okay he takes
if I take with Knights I'm completely
out of the theory here I could take with
night I could take the pawn and I could
take on d4 with pawn so quantity for
1984 they take t5 if we trade as rip d1
and if I take with pond okay I'll take
with pollen first
you
usually like when the Queen develops so
early to see - you want your knight to
come to c6 because then there's more
opportunities to exploit the Queen I'm
not sure whether to take a neither pawn
here
taketake
go take with pawn I'm giving myself an
IQ p but like whites behind the
developments his queens on c2 is king
still in the center
I'm already castled and I'm hoping to
like put enough pressure where his
scheme will be stuck in the center I
don't know if it's possible though but
we'll see d1
you
kal throw-in h6l throw-in h6
maybe Bishop c4
you might just respond with Bishop e2
yeah if I play like night before
could be a month
wait then queen bee three
okay change the plans I'm gonna play
Bishop wait no Bishop h5 doesn't do
anything so you can take it what am I
doing here take take
okay I have an idea I don't know if it's
a good idea but we're trading because
I'm trying to keep the initiative
usually when you trade and you have an
IQ P it's not a good thing but yeah I
was hoping you would take with Knights
yeah this is just more pleasant for
whites Bishop c5 does that do anything
oh he takes on d5 ouch
wait this is just bad
I might have to go crazy I'm gonna go
crazy I'm gonna play g5 and then just
Bishop c5 and I've been spending too
much time um the plan is to maybe play
d4 or at least make it sharp enough so
he can blunder
moving too slow it's uncomfortable okay
I'll go for d4
the problem is there's this pin I'm not
actually threatening anything Bishop II
thought it was probably a good move I
take it doesn't work
I'm just completely falling apart this
game
searching for counterplay there's
nothing there
I'm just gonna be down a pond with a bad
position and the phone's ringing again
let's do this scholar okay let's take
and then do this dalip on down on time
that's the type of position it's very
hard to get counterplay keep rooks on
the board he's gonna move quickly which
is maybe not a bad thing because maybe
hold blunder somewhere I do have some
Center control um it's a pawn storm a 5
B 4 pond storm is probably not going
anywhere I have to do that probably this
centralizer king
to that maybe night here
it's good
ah good move
he's playing very well this is so
unfortunate
draw
fons I do have a night you're never
supposed to resign when you have a night
III s attacks twice
please just get Forks
kindiy three please just to me something
I can do that
you
maybe 95 walk into
g6 will also walk into a fork
I'm resisting hashtag resist
you
but this is looking bad unless he plays
g6 please play g6
oh now g6 is a good move oh so sad
ooh wait do you give me something
probably not I have one second left
maybe hole carelessly stalemate me no oh
it's so unfortunate I just got in
trouble from the opening I think I
played too hopefully thinking the center
should open up in my favor but it was
just positional Bishop g4 was a bad move
what's the move to play maybe I should
just take with Knights like avoid the
bad structure I mean if he takes on u7 I
can take back with Knights and then it's
just a normal position I would play e5
okay
tough game first loss of the day back to
tournaments I'm in third place
oh it's Queen 85m if I wasn't looking at
the chance but Queen a5 it will point
maybe after a c5 and then rook d1 ha
okay I'm playing a patron cool it's play
d4 I'm gonna berserk because I'm on tilt
oh it made the berserk sound but it
didn't piss urgh
that's annoying okay well I was a moment
too late this is usually a fun line I
played this position many many many
times before yes to trade I get the a
file I go for B for ideas and Knight d2
to b3 and he's already thinking which is
good
I could win a pawn right away I gotta
take on ba din' then take here only
thing is he has b6 in the end but waits
to stop upon let's do that oh now he's
going for a rook
a8 which could also be annoying so I
can't get too comfortable here to play
f3 f3 looks reasonable
I think the idea is if he plays rook a
they take here and in okay one I would
have King f2 also may be preparing some
like storm like g4 why not g4 h four and
then G five maybe even before just my
last like several moves have been pawn
moves
I should probably develop at some point
get my King off the e-file let's play
Bishop h3 with tempo this night is
almost trapped has to go to f8 I could
play f4
and now I want to bring a Knight to e5
and as bishop is just staring into empty
space like it's doing nothing from d3
and 95 will come and maybe there's some
Mike King side attack happening
blazing heart for you
I like the emotes I think I have the
same emotes right I will respond wait I
can't respond wait what oh there we go
okay Fiona happy as this meets this
looks like it's about to be mates he6
free move with the mates that's nice
not sure is Bishop on e7 is much better
yeah this Bishop both bishops were kind
of sad a good game open open 55 okay so
in third place within reach of the
leader who continues to berserk
what emotes do you have for your channel
I have this one and this one and this
one I think it only gives me three
emotes I tried adding more but to add a
new one I have to delete an old one
however I reached like the partnership
requirements and I applied to be a
partner last week so if that goes
through then hopefully all has many more
emails to choose from or to create so
with that being said if anyone has any
emailed ideas please let me know what is
this opening I'm gonna play a5 and try
and do stuff which probably doesn't work
986 such random moves but I'm trying to
make sense of of something here maybe
push it a 5 and then bring the knight in
start with e 6 I'm getting a weird
buzzing
it could just be my my cheap headset
it's every once in a while is that
happening to anyone else I wonder if
it's like the microphone hitting
something plugged in okay I have no idea
it changes when he moves oh okay I'll
look into that wait is there a noise
suppression filter settings audio
where's my filter settings filters noise
suppression the filter is there okay I'm
gonna listen to the stream and then
trying to figure out what the issue is
see twitch where's my twitch channel
twitch TV
in the meantime D for looks really weak
can I just somehow win it like Knight g4
Knight g4 is 92 but then c5 there's a
ton of pressure
okay I'm listening for the buzzing
sounds I'm not hearing it
I know sometimes like when I talk the
like the wind picks up on the the
microphone it's kind of the nature of
this headset can I take on d4 wait if I
take on d4 could take with check wait a
minute if I take with the bishop oh he
takes with Knight this looks very close
to being good there's a funny move here
I'm just going to play h5 I continue to
calculate because I don't think you can
take on g4
and the pressure remains she tries to
defend
I'll see five I'm being very ambitious
oh yeah if axe villager can clip it that
would be nice
it happened when you said I'm not
hearing it haha the problem is I can't
listen to myself talk for long periods
because I'm it just messes with my brain
oh he keeps defending his pawn wait six
take take I guess I can simplify if I
want to I want to simplify but maybe I
have to
okay I'm gonna simplify thanks for the
follow blazing heart for you oh I guess
he doesn't have to take like he could
still think about taking this which I
just kind of assumed it's still defended
but it's not defended okay let me listen
to this okay he takes it this is gonna
get interesting because I'm down a piece
okay let me focus down a piece I have an
h-file I have a d4 pawn IV five maybe
of g3
g3 seems like the move to start with
because if he can play g3 it's probably
a bit more comfortable for him but now
there's like all these different mating
ideas uh let me just make ax villager a
moderator oh let's not ban him mod user
okay there you go
congratulations X villager one of the
loyal viewers to the stream - can i play
e5 here e5 yeah that's pretty funny
have to be aggressive okay I saw or I
listened to the clip oh I'm low on time
this is bad King f8 I'm not going to
worry about the buzzing sound for the
time being I do have to fix my position
first
this is a really sharp really complex
thirty-seconds is not a lot of time for
this situation so I'll probably have to
plant instincts
I think the thread is just to take on f4
maybe even rook h4 there's 93
possibilities there's a lot of like
candidate moves to consider I just have
to play quickly what is he gonna play
you play there and that's promises
Knight is gonna be destabilized oh
that's a good move haha
what do i do let's do that maybe f6
coming next the ship c1 was a good move
another good move moving too slowly
you
this is still very complex
oh can you trade Queens that would be
bad
this is really bad now I should not have
allowed that don't it was possible
though so another game I'm about to lose
unless I can somehow pawn storm and
checkmate him which is probably very
unlikely but we'll try remove rock f2
you know if I had more time maybe this
would be winnable but 10 seconds left
ouch or maybe if he has more time all
right if he has less time it would be
winnable can I win that pawn I'll pre
move something here or not I can move
very good move to use my king king power
ah stressful stressful stressful
no he mated me oh that was another game
lost yeah I'm sorry about the audio
issue with the buzzing I have no idea it
sounds like there might be an issue with
the connection or so it's like it
doesn't sound like it's actually coming
from the environment I have no idea I
could increase a filter any
recommendations in the chats and this
feels bad getting a hundred plus viewers
I haven't even looked at the viewers it
doesn't look like I have on your cross
viewers but maybe that was in the past
okay we are gonna move on I'm gonna
still try and fight for first place Wow
I'm falling behind because I lost two
games and I've lost my streak which
probably means I'm gonna be on tilt for
the next several games and I'll probably
bizarre a bit more do you have a cell
phone nearby I don't even know where my
cell phone is I don't think it's nearby
okay let's bezerk gonna play e5e for and
we'll play some French to Knights attack
hey Siri where are you serious being
passive-aggressive okay
let's do this Bishop e7 it's not a
common move most people play c5 let's
play Bishop f4 this is going to be a
weird position I'll take ya that's kind
of annoying I have to play Bishop e2
this is usually the good Bishop should
not be traded off
you
you
oh I see my phone I don't need it right
now though okay
the typical plan for white is to play
like h5 h6 and try and provoke
weaknesses
the other plan is to play rock h3 rope
g3 which
and sometimes both these plans can
happen I'll start with h5
I'm trying to like make him play g6 so
that I can start targeting his his pawn
d4 is probably a good move I have to
retreat
I go to a2 because I want to reposition
to d3 oh he's playing well a lot of
people playing well today so he could
win g2 but then I would probably win g7
Queen d2 make it sharp whoa that's a
good move
that's a really good move
is on points
take take - I just oh wait no I have
this amount of Queen Siwon
okay I'm not losing guts hopefully or
maybe I am
I lose f2 but maybe there's counter play
or he's just yeah he's completely out
playing me Bishop
f3 maybe
you
my gosh t3
trying to survive wait I take no then D
- wow so strong
I'm getting completely crushed
I forgot to take opening recommendations
I'll play the Scotch
if someone allows it wait what am I even
doing King do you wanna only move
you
yeah this guy's playing pretty pretty
flawlessly
very nice that was brutal
I was really brutal like every move was
just like a punch in the face like every
single move starting with D for just
kept getting punched like every every
move he makes a threat every move that's
the power of initiative ouch my face is
so in pain right now
analysis board let me just run the thing
request cool okay back to tournament
this is painful I've lost like three
games sort of back-to-back almost three
in a row I need some some energy I need
some motivation to fight back I'm gonna
be Zurich again cuz eventually I'll have
to win oh this guy's leading the
tournament the guy I just played you
know what yeah I'm letting the oh my
gosh and I now slip
well at least you didn't take so this is
actually a playable position it's not
intended to play e5 there but okay it's
not lost I just have to move quickly any
move that's not critical I'm gonna play
very quickly yeah people are already
being suspicious in the chats which it's
unfortunate maybe I'll get my rating
refunds
okay at least this is a playable
position he was nice to me and didn't
take on e5 earlier let's do this
going for b5 and it should be sudden
goodbye it's a moment LAN oh sorry you
have to go
yeah the mouse what is the biggest
tilter ever I was more of a trackpad
slip I still have to figure out how to
integrate my new Mouse with my MacBook
cuz I plugged it in and it like it
worked terribly maybe I need a mousepad
I don't know what we for is kind of weak
here
I'm already threatening before or
threatening just to take he's gonna play
95 but I might as well go into the slime
95 okay let's take and then play a five
sneaky threats
you
try and contest you file
maybe queen of six will come next
hitting f4 hanging b2
yeah so it worked terribly because it
was really slow like I would move it and
I would move it across the table I would
move like halfway across the screen
I put the sensitivity like all the way
up so I think like the issue is I need
to install some kind of like mouse
software to have more functionality but
I don't know where to get that software
so it's gonna require further research I
take I think I can take um the one thing
it did do for me though like cuz I was
so slow with the mouse it gave me more
confidence on the trackpad like it just
made me feel better about myself using
the trackpad he's attacking two things I
think I can play queen d4 first hit the
bishop guess it depends where his king
goes I might play rook e7 next the
problem is there's all these back right
mates tricks king h1 is a good move as
rookie 7 runs into Queen to b7
so maybe just working a fates he takes
my bishop I take his bishop if he takes
my knight I take back and I hit I hit
the rook on c1 which he forgot about
that's nice take can do this what Mouse
is it it's a Logitech oh man I forget
let me do a search for it Logitech man
I've been giving Logitech some great
business lately g502 it's like it's
supposed to be a professional gamer
Mouse the Proteus spectrum like in the
past week I bought um I bought the
Logitech mouse I bought the Logitech
webcam and now this headset - oh thanks
for the link axe villager let me
download that maybe I can like download
it midstream and then has my mouse
working by the end of the tournament Mac
oh there's a Mac download okay nice
wait but does it work for the mouse
Oh added support for those mice okay
wait is this just means looks like maids
okay back to tournament download now 189
megabyte school I'm in seventh place not
the end of the world still above 2,300
this guy suspicious I guess because he
won all his games he's ever played on me
chess oh he's lost a few games okay um
oh I did want to look at the game that
he played against me a bit closer but
let's focus on this game first
well he's busy working too which is nice
and he's playing Sicilian we'll play my
my pet line Grand Prix style whoa f5
what is this he five maybe what is he
doing I've never seen this idea before I
thought of and then b5 it's crazy
I'm just gonna play normal moose c4 is
actually pretty logical he doesn't want
his pawns to become too weak maybe I can
attack him
maybe b3 first
ideas of Bishop III and you can't play
b4 cos Bishop take me for that's nice
let's play Bishop d6 I'm up upon c4 is
coming d4 is coming this is nice
go for a sneaky mates and his king stuck
in the center too okay he defends like
to continue attacking I could just play
d4 ideas of this
you
9si too aggressive the thing is my
bishop is probably better than his rook
I'm gonna keep my Bishop for a bit
longer cause I feel like I can win
quicker by keeping the Bishop on c5
there has to be some day I can get into
e7 I just have to distract these two
pieces but he plays 93 okay we'll take
and then do this when they pawn and then
get the rook to a seven okay seven
Queens igby three Queenie seven game
over I think I guess he has a knight f2
and then Queen e3 but just about game
over
mmm where's the mate
taketake
I don't see a clear win or a forced win
we'll do this and then this should be
good enough
again like 9f2 queenie 3 is actually a
threats so i have to feel a little bit
careful
you
I'm just going to be ultra safe like
rook f1
you
I guess we can trade and push puns
actually let's do this first and that
that's nice
the admin team is asleep interesting
you
okay good game six place hopefully this
guy gets knocked out before the
tournament ends sky the zurka ng almost
every game playing Sultan 1800 I played
many times before we're doing another
bird opening type already play him this
tournament maybe not okay
doing something I don't even know what
we call this it's a very unusual setup
played t6 I played him I guess I play
them in like a similar line already oh
that was a game where I went crazy and
tried to win the d4 pawn and then just
got punished um yeah let's not do that
again what to do night before oh my gosh
I feel like going crazier I just want to
like take on e3 and then oh it doesn't
work it doesn't work then it's probably
a good thing if I've stole a crazy move
I just want to like open more lines
especially this diagonal maybe this file
okay people saying I did play him yeah
I'll take stuff is opening up T 3 is now
week maybe C 4 will come
I think c4 is a useful move in many
cases like right now because of Queen
ticks I take on e3 and if pawn takes it
opens up attack for the bishop and I
plate nighty-night to D 3 and when the
rook moves I win the e3 pawn Knight e4
is a good move which I kind of forgot
about can I take on e3 night c2 in the
end probably not just do this
quiet move but he can't actually take
back on c4 if he takes with Queen
there's B 5 if he takes with pod I win
the Knights meanwhile wait what just b5
Oh Quincy 5 but then 93
okay
relax winning something
I think Knight III guess he has bishops
III but then Queen c7 and this is
hanging and this is hanging and this is
hanging with so many things hanging
maybe I take the rook first okay good
game climbing back up found the streak
again ah what was with that game what
was a sent upon loss oh not that one
this one yeah zero and accuracy zero
mistake zero point is especially be
seven actually the computer
recommendation it's up there like a
second Wow yeah hopefully the mod step
in let's do this
Oh berserk I remembered yes okay so we
have some London again bread and butter
92 just going for the classic London
setup usually four is good in positions
like this as funny if he takes twice
then his rook gets trapped on eight
so he'll probably play Bishop b7 and
yeah I can play 96 96 we trade that's
played 96 now there's some bishop pair I
think it's Pleasant for a white maybe
not a huge advantage but it's the type
of position I can build things up I'm
very tempted to play Bishop e5 because
after I take take light moves I might
have a great gift just going to rely on
intuition Knight g4 runs into Bishop th7
I think
yeah this looks fun I'm not calculating
I think this is a way to play blitz
let's go with the guts and the big
problem here like there's f7 hanging and
this also happening maybe I don't have
anything you could just defend f7 but at
least I win g7 and then I threaten f7 so
there's compensation but is there enough
Brook ad1 coming oh he gives me that son
but then he wants to play rookie seven
so take okay let's start with this and
then queen g6 Oh
but then 9f for that should still be
okay now that for Brooke 81
there should be enough attack counter
play
because he probably has to block on d5
whoa what is this
Queeny for okay this is looking good
if 95 I take on an e6 this is very nice
okay have some momentum here
I mean you can just resign I would be
the nicest or not Queen d7 is a good try
take take there wait how do I win not
for maybe the most simple move this
wasn't the simplest Greek gift I must
say but now it's looking pretty simple
as King has nowhere to go nowhere to
hide
but not all Greek gifts are good like
there could be there could be a whole
book written on Greek gifts because
there's so many different situations
where like it almost works but it
doesn't work or it's really complicated
like this position that wasn't clear I
think you had better chances to defend
wait and he's actually putting up some
resistance here has to be careful about
the back rank and my time
but I have three connected pass pawns
start with h4
I'm just gonna keep pushing keep pushing
let's continue to push
keep pushing
oh he wants to like have rugby one so
I'll play King G to not give him
anything
you
throwing the check
another check keep pushing
that's for coming next
you
you
as our maid somewhere let's throw in a
check it's almost meat
okay we'll pre move the X this is good
enough
okay good game a cool third-place oh
that guy lost a game interesting someone
too strong so I'm one more win away from
first place this guy has been leading
for a while
mage in over an hour left it's been a
while since I played like a whole
tournament like this
let's bezerk and let's be aggressive if
he lets me maybe he won't let H three
what's H three let's play C five and
then take H three is such a weird move
okay this is already like a nice
position more Center more center pawns
he has a bad Bishop which Mike
fianchetto or might not grab more Center
push any of the planets to bring the
Queen to e5 that's a little bit annoying
I throw in the check or can I take wait
what's going on here
check and then play queen e5 this might
be completely unsound but maybe it works
somehow I don't know what's going on
here
my bishops hanging but his bishops
hanging is Knights under threat there
might be a bishop a six in the end but
then he has a four oh maybe I have no d4
and I take t4 Oh
let's finish basics hold on to that pawn
for as long as possible maybe even go
for d2 with the discovered attack or
we'll trade
and then retreats
objectively White's probably a little
bit better just due to pawn structure
but I'm gonna try and get some attack
maybe 94 rope g6 let's not trade the
rooks
now I'm hitting the bishop and the pawn
also opening up g6 ideas
and rook g6 could be hard to meet I'm
expecting a move like okay bishop you've
won I can play rough g6 maybe he asked
to play g3 is there a breakthrough maybe
not
okay let's defend apply this to continue
attacking the h5h four on the horizon
it's so inspiring to see you play chess
well that common is pretty inspiring
Thank You axe villager I have a knight
g4 94 or queen g4 so I queen G for
keeping the knight defending the pawn
someday I'll wanna play Knight g4 and
his bishop is just complete garbage here
so he probably heard me but now I'll
play Knight e4 again hitting the bishop
an f2 he'll probably go back I wanna
play rook da but then rook to e4
I don't want to repeat maybe I have to
repeat
ugh okay let's repeat once
a chief or he doesn't want to repeat
interesting
well I'll throw in rip to you
and I guess my g4
you
I'm trying to be sneaky somehow like
some kind of Queen to gage for ideas
they probably don't work right away
now they definitely don't work I have to
move quicker
Queen h3 ideas she allows that's nice
but I have to prove myself I just
blundered no but he didn't see it's good
let's do this he could have taken on e4
there well now he takes on you for
interesting it still difficult 19
seconds left I have to focus and stop
talking
you
that's a free bishop Wow
I might actually win this that's a pre
moving
okay now I should definitely win this
assuming I don't flag so a classic
ladder meets pretty sure I could win
with win this with uh with one second
left just don't use all your time come
on I wasn't looking at the chat because
I was kind of preoccupied but now I have
a quick break
India yeah I think there's a lot of
Indian viewers um did you win the
tournament in Chicago yeah I did win the
tournament
I like the Bobby Fischer Memorial
whatever okay oh we're gonna move on hey
I mean it's a first place tied for first
I have my streak
oh you saw me in there interesting it
was a big turnouts there are a lot of
people there and I know like there was
some other people there that were like
regular viewers to the stream but I
don't think I met them how did you do
metallic or meta eleven ink let's bezerk
again let's play e5 new opening two
Knights do I accept forty year old
students I take students of all levels
and all ages so yes mighty for it's
probably a new move for him um which is
good it's a tricky line
around 1650 yeah if you're interested in
lessons you can use the moobot command
lessons and then you can find out more
c3 is main line and after it be 5 it's
gonna get messy oh thank you exa ways
for the the 100 bits here for number one
hopefully I can keep that that place
it's a good sign when my opponents
thinking and in what's actually a
somewhat popular variation um this is
not a common line but maybe it's
playable and I actually don't know
what's going on in this position Tay or
Bishop d7 he takes maybe e4 White has
triple pawns that looks kind of
interesting now then he has d6 d6 so
maybe I'll play h6 first I guess you
could take an e5 and there's more weird
trading going on this still looks fun
cuz black has two bishops I have to open
h-file Bishop d6 is coming my king will
be very safe on f8 and he has massive
problems with this H pawn because if he
plays h3 then there's g4 if he plays g3
it's weakening to all the light squares
actually there's a funny line if he
plays g3 maybe ripped a gauge to King
take h2 Queen take F to and it's
completely winning for luck so yeah it's
one of these positions like I already
have so many pieces attacking on the
Kings side he just completely ignores
everything I take with Bishop rook let's
take with bishop and then bishop g3
you
oh I hope I'm not running into 94-94
okay at the very worst I have this and
then Bishop g4 wait a minute Bishop g4
King D what's going on King d3 maybe I
just take take take take why don't I see
a clear win here
this is really frustrating
taketake
you
can I go with this
I guess I have ff5 move just hoping for
something better
but we're just trading more maybe blacks
not better here which would be really
unfortunate
I could play okay he's gonna take the
bishop I have rook e8 d3 Queen to g3
I'll go for f5 just win the piece back
how many pawns does each side have
I have for his six no he's five no he
has six I can't count
but now he has five and rookie eights
coming oh but then he trades Queens
so King g8 first King g8 I think is a
very powerful move because rook f8 is
very hard to stop and there's massive
attack play the Berlin I don't think so
I guess I could I don't think I've ever
played the Berlin before it's just one
of these moves
I would rather or one of these openings
I'd rather not play yeah please keep
reminding me what openings I should play
in the chat because people were giving
me suggestions a while ago but it was
during a game and then I just forgot but
caro-kann okay I'll make an effort
bishop where do I go Bishop h3 I guess
I'm threatening Bishop take g2
this is still not easy to win though
this is gonna take work oh I had rookie
why didn't I play rookie
I was so focused on the g2 pond
hoping this is so good
you
that's and annoying move rook f6 maybe
this game is really important for the
standings - I want to submit my lead
I have to like hunker down like move
with the bishop back to a5 make sure he
doesn't have counterplay against my king
it's good that he's thinking though
and see that coming yes or take then
that he doesn't have checks
it's going to be a time scramble just
not ideal
Queen FA is only one check
okay I have one check
you
I have to try and flag them
you
you
you
it will trade Queens
it's a funny position okay I flagged him
I feel dirty about that but okay that's
the nature let's and I did berserk so he
had time odds out he had a huge time
advantage to he was up a queen so I
can't feel too bad but slightly dirty
okay so I'm back on a winning streak
life is good
I don't think I got my rating refunds
that's okay let's fizzer again I will
play you for again who wanted uh who was
suggesting a white opening well okay
Alec I guess I have to play into
Alekhine I'm just gonna play what I know
it's to play c4 and then usually the
night goes to D 2 and B 3 Bishop b2 this
is really all I know
and the bishop goes to e 2 I think it's
a nice setup the only thing about this
opening like you have to be careful not
to lose this pawn which is currently
defended because my knight defends the
Knights so if he takes I take back with
Knights a5 let's play a3
if you wants to play a 4 I can play B 4
looks pleasant play h3 rook e1 maybe
might f1 night g3 ideas
yeah I can't complain
how about already okay remind me next
time I'm white just tell me to play
ready and I'll be ready to play the
ready knee chest miles resting today
okay
oh I don't really want to trade but
there's a lot of pressure on this pawn
let's play Queen d2 I want to play b5
and not allow 95
you
it's pretty positional working up my
space of an inch one of the drawbacks
for black and the plate b6 drawback for
black as this pawn on a four at some
points should be captured and that might
determine the game like long term if I
can win the pawn and I March my a pawn
down that's the dream
but maybe there's a few approaches here
the play Queen f4 looks like a nice fur
for the Queen
maybe preparing 95 yeah why not how
spawns still defended whoa okay I can
win upon now winning d4 or am i yeah I
think I am
cuz Rick do you want he has d3 though
Wow
so we're getting some opposite color
Bishop position I feel like white should
be better um but maybe I'm just pulling
a kramnik Queen c4
I wanna play f4 f5 and just like kill
him or at least block the bishop so I
can win the pawn h5 is probably a
reasonable move I'll do this and then
King g3 defend
there's also six ideas maybe someday
sometime open this diagonal but let's
start by pushing that fun actually I
have to start by playing King g3 or
trading Queens oh wow put the bishop on
d4 in this case I think the pawn wants
to be on f3 so if I play f4 he plays
Bishop b4 so weird position let's play
whoa can't play rugby one
what's going on here wants to play rugby
five
you
rook t2
yes rooks getting in that's annoying
play f3
I don't know what's going on here all I
know is I have to move quickly it's
going to be another tough fight double
up on the H file
wait a minute that's not good okay let's
do this
he's gonna play Bishop before that I
play f5 and I have some passed pawn
possibilities I have to trade em where's
my passport I can get to pass phones I
could play c6 - wait a minute I could
play rook b2 and then c6 or c6 and then
rugby - that should work I think d4 I
don't know I don't know what's going on
here let's try this because he might be
excited to take and then go into the
opposite color Bishop ending or not
let's do this I just want to play c6 oh
so he's gonna play rook c1 or not okay
well this is nice work h2 does nothing I
think he had to play rook c1 there
there's now the pawns start pushing 24
seconds should be a lot of time
wait to see a perpetual no he has no
perpetual I was scared rook h3 King at 4
would almost would walk into me and
actually this is just over
what to do how do I win quickly make
another queen
to Queens there's a lot of Queens Oh bye
it's too short calm day on Achatz adios
I don't know about details what I
haven't been following the chat kingi
show is blessing me okay
that's nice oh let's continue hey I have
a lead seven-point lead that's nice
that's one way of putting it
T Dunlap
okay 48 more minutes left I might take a
small break at some point because I need
to like survive need to nourish nourish
myself let me get a drink oh let's not
actually let's wait until after this
game um he's in second place let's
reinforce my Dominus oh I wanted to
reinforce my dominance by deserting him
but I guess it's a double berserk
he badly needs a win East sixth let's
play what do I play here G 3.92 let's
play G three and this line nine H three
is a move let's keep up the pace Bishop
d6 what is this move so weird move
so he's gonna play D sixes but it's just
a weird piece and then maybe I play f5
whoa oh I forgot all the open crackin
sedation's again I apologize for that
let's do this
but this is a very serious game to use
my strongest opening to beat the sky
f5 yeah five very thematic Bishop g5
such a nice square for the bishop I can
with a pawn maybe let's win a pawn I'm
not scared of c4 check very easy met
with d4 I'll just build up he does have
worked 83 here but then I have rook take
off 7 should be good for whites let's
hide do this
what do I do triple up looks decent oh
he wants to meet me what I came out of
nowhere
that's almost winning it's like one move
to the fend that was almost scared me
he might be winning the exchange here or
not
okay this is actually a bit complicated
so the bishops are good my nights out of
play
I'll do this now my nights in play okay
that was easy
and then that's a fork he's probably
going to sack on g2 but I don't think
there's any harm here
because this rook can't really can unpin
myself
take a free pawn
and now I have passers
you
okay life is good up on time and I'm
gonna get the buzzer King points to
assuming I can invert this let's play
rook g7 King g4 okay he's being annoying
I'm just gonna simplify just trade and
then push should be good enough keep
pushing keep pushing
that's a check let's do that
very important when you want to promote
an H pawn and you have a knight you want
your knight on f7 controlling h8 key
idea
okay this is a key win 43 minutes left
back to tournaments it's 66 points I'm
just gonna be Zurich the rest of the
games I have to keep keep up the streak
I think now the goal is to break 2400
oh just network is playing where is he
maybe he joined late I don't even see
chess network did he just join where are
you that's so weird
whoa there's a lot of players in this
tournament
there's over 1400 players okay it's a
lot of people Linnell is saying I played
oh he plays Knight c3 Sicilian nice
scotch game I'll play the Scotch if he
plays e5 or yeah if he plays e5 this is
a scotch or it's about to be the Scotch
but you want a scotch gambits or what
you want or just standard scotch please
tell me I'm just waiting for ax
villagers comments tell me what to do
ex villager Scotch Hedgehog
I'm waiting okay if I fall below
okay classical Scotch cool I don't know
too much classical scotch a Bishop III I
think is a classical move and then c3
and there's a few ideas here like to
play g3 or I think g3 is kind of a nice
solid line put the bishop on g2 oh yes
to refresh yeah maybe he's uh fallen
behind this looks pleasant for whites I
actually used to play the Scotch back
when I was in high school a long time
ago and I would get positions like this
or it's just a bit more comfortable for
whites the question is what to do next
like both players sometimes run out of
things to do I might consider playing I
like I want to play nine a three here I
think ninety two is very reasonable
and at some point like throwing this
move each three wait did I just allow an
IG for that's not good it's one of those
things I just kind of forgot about um
yeah you should not allow tonight chief
or I should have played h3 first
probably it's embarrassing I think it's
still playable like I'll take McKnight
if it takes a bishop
and well maybe it's not too bad
weights still doing well well I know
take with Queen if I took on the night
with the Queen the bishop would capture
sometimes it's hard to see faraway
pieces like that
do you take opening choices for your
games yeah I asked for opening
recommendations earlier and people gave
me a bunch of openings to play and then
I just kind of forgot what everyone said
but then Acts villager is said to play
the Scotch and I played the Scotch it's
95 I move for black I think that was an
old comment 95 is a move for whites and
Queens e8 is only move let's play 4
let's play f4 f4 is usually accompanied
by King h1
and just gaining space the dream
scenario is to play King each one the
knight b5 in this pawn is weak play the
penguin gm1 opening what is that can you
play the French defense the one where
you put the pawns together and no take
them wait what so not the French
exchange probably the advanced variation
one night h3 I don't really mess with I
know it's an opening but I don't know
it's a bit too hipster for me
Carol Colin could play I was gonna play
caro-kann earlier but then I forgot so
Carol kaan
let me just make a list you open up like
a note document
caro-kann so if black caro-kann someone
said Alekhine like ages ago i think
those were the two black openings and
then the white openings we have wait
once oh we have French defence also for
black cool as said earlier you have a
hundred plus viewers when you're a
beginner which openings variations must
you know openings like opening theory is
not too important when you're a beginner
because most of the games you'll play
are not determined solely by the opening
but you you want to have like something
that you're comfortable playing so like
choose maybe a couple simple lines or
like a system to play like a London
system or a king's immune system just to
set up where like you know where your
pieces should go but yeah as you
progresses the chess player then
openings become more relevant
okay this position really transforms now
it's about kind of breaking through on
the kingside the long-term plan is to
play g4 actually now it's the short-term
plan and I just want to open up some
wine I might even like double up and
then when the time is right we'll take
on that five
hi mr. Feingold is been final here wait
once then Feingold is he lurking I don't
think he's here or is he why are people
mentioning been Feingold okay rook G to
double up everyone's saying hi Feingold
but I think everyone's just
hallucinating severely confused if I
take that doesn't do anything I'm just
gonna play b3 solid
Oh what do I do I'm gonna try and triple
up maybe I don't think I meant to play
g5 but too late oh oh this is really
scary he's playing well all of a sudden
okay we'll take and then take care still
alive sort of b1 under control I played
some bad moves there might be one
blockade
oh it's bad wait I can just no I can't
take I want to take next move
you
mmm oh no this is really bad
no I have to flag him it's only hope
a whole position how am I losing to a
1600 this is so bad this is so bad
baby train and we do that we keep
checking him and we try and find him
okay this is such low quality chess yes
oh that was dirty again I'm sorry to my
opponent for doing that to him but
that's let's uh let's not look back on
that game I think I was getting
distracted like people were answering or
asking questions in the chat and then
the ghosts have been flying gold
appeared and everyone was saying hi to
him but that was nice keeping up the
berserk streak
I just want to assert my dominance and
I'll bezerk again
were there any recommendations against
e4 I guess I'll try to play the French
against e4 she doesn't let me let's play
b6 new opening
maybe we just transpose into a Queen's
in you okay I have to move faster this
game this used to be one of like the
main lines I played like in tournaments
ready to play a whole line with Bishop
b4 check and see five I can take and
it's going to be some hydraulic
structure where I think it's a solid
position that could be a long fight so a
six stopping any Knight b5 stuff very
often the bishop goes back to c5 or even
a sudden I'll start with Bishop c5
because this nice kind of awkward maybe
I go for like an early d5 or maybe not
waits Bishop II one play d5
because of the e-file opens like this
pawn on f3 is kind of a dump on and pawn
on e2 is kind of backwards I'll play
rookie AIDS now I do have the IQ p but I
don't think it's a terrible thing he's
thinking about playing b4 here and if I
take you can take here and then Queen d6
it should be okay for black I think what
headphones are those these are the
logitech something
I think it's each 390 I'm not mistaken I
was like the only thing I could find at
targets
yesterday I would have ordered something
on Amazon but I didn't want to wait a
day for it to arrive
it's impatience these cost me about 45
dollars in the store and they were like
$20 on Amazon with like two day free
shipping so wasn't the best decision
probably what I'll end up doing do I
want to do here h5 I'll probably return
these and then look to get just a more
reliable mic because I don't think the
durability of these are that great just
needed a short-term solution this
position looks really nice because his
pieces are ridiculous like this Knight
and Bishop what is he doing if she's
attacking d5 and sort of c5 and if I
play d4 he is Knight c4 let's attack the
Knights I'll probably have to play d4 at
some points I want to attack him somehow
I'll do this like this
is actually somewhat solid for him
there's no clear breakthrough but
there's some tricky idea which I can't
do anymore but I can take because I
attack is Queen which I think you missed
because now like everything's hanging
this is hanging this is hanging this is
gonna hang at some points only move I
don't know what to do against is this so
let me calculate he goes there and then
rook d2 probably okay now I just went a
full rook that's nice
more buzzer King we're winning cool
extending the lead I could probably drop
out now and win the tournament but I'll
try and keep it up chestnut work in 65th
place maybe I'll play him towards the
end of the event beyond the mask if you
want something really reasonable price
headphones are good wait once get two
okay let me look that up
let's buzzer again wait I have to use a
washroom I'll be right back
let me just get to a position where he
starts thinking and I'm gonna take a
quick break
or maybe just after this game oh he's
playing quickly Queen c1 what do I do
against this movie I guess Bishop f5 my
previous pair of headphones still exist
I usually use air pods the problem with
air pods they have a built-in microphone
but the built-in microphone is terrible
and then I have these whatever these are
that came with my iPhone a problem is it
comes with this like cable which doesn't
use isn't compatible with my computer
so life is complicated
hopefully rook c8 and this is gonna be
the more like kind of tense game where
we both kind of complete development I
think I'll take castle not do any
unnecessary trades blacks already
slightly better here I hello to chess G
welcome back
let's not trade off the bishop
I value my bishops five doesn't quite
work yet so let's castle ninety four
should come ninety four some initiative
here maybe a five I just want to like
poke at him like poke at many different
things and maybe provoke some blunder
like b2 is already a potential target
like a for stuff happening and I'm I'm
avoiding like all trades for most trades
and minor pieces just so that he's a bit
more cramps because I have more space
with the pawn on d5 can we name your
subscribers the rosebuds oh yeah I mean
whatever you want to be names I'm okay
with the rosebuds it's an interesting
name if you're willing to spend three
hundred fifty on the headset oh my gosh
okay um let me know okay beyond the mask
seems very knowledgeable about like
headset and just equipment streaming
equipments so let me let me tell you
what I want or what I look for in the
product and then let me know if there's
a product like it I want something
that's very lightweight and portable
because I travel a lot I want to just be
able to throw something in my backpack
that's not a blue Yeti microphone this
that's a fork so something lightweight
and portable and with good audio quality
that like it's it does a good job of
like drowning out background noise if
I'm in like a busier setting like an
airport or like cafe or whatever and it
can just be a headphone like bird it can
just be a microphone it doesn't have to
be a full like headset so if there's any
microphone which exists that's easy to
travel with that can reduce background
noise that works well with streaming let
me know because I'm I'm open to
suggestions I'll look up okay I'll have
to look up the beyerdynamic MX and then
X but let's focus in this position he's
attacking me Bishop b5 is actually very
resourceful because if I take either PC
take some minutes and I don't think I
win anything Wow it's kind of pulled
some miracle here but I think I can take
the bishop and then take on e3 and also
have some initiative uh wow it's gonna
take work to win this he said he's
attacking the rook who's gonna play like
rook to e1 I'm not even like up upon
he's winning a4 I would be too
might take some dirtiness to win this
game
it's been a lot of dirtiness today rook
e8 looks very nice rook e8 8 because now
wait am i winning anything
I don't see your tactic there should be
tactics there I'm not seeing it it gets
to flaking h1 she's not desirable oh no
now I'm walking into tactics no okay I
don't know how I'm gonna win this I'm so
long time I need to resist I need to
play quickly maybe set up some tricks on
how I really didn't want to trade the
bishop pair but I guess I have to throw
the bishop back on b8 the Queen on f6
first
I'm gonna stop talking and play chess
wait a minute did he just plunder well
he just gave me mate Wow
okay stop talking and that's what
happens uh he had Queen h3 here and
whites so much better that was nice
uh Rosa Rosebud's you have to pronounce
that right okay who did you who did
impress you most in candidates
I mean Fabiano always impressive I'm
gonna be right back in the meantime I'll
just leave this game open who ever wants
to watch just quick a quick break
Petra off defense yes the pressure off
defense is very fine especially as
Fabiano is playing it and winning with
it even if it's against chronic I'll be
right back
you
you
you
well I'm back so there's no time to
gossip about me getting the impression
Eric isn't the biggest fan of cranek I I
mean I'm actually a big fan of cranek
just as tournaments it's easy to make
fun of him
but I've really admired his play am I
gonna be zerk this game I guess
why not oh let's play quickly and he's
gonna play quickly too okay Queen b6 I
think is a move wait is Queen b6 a move
I guess it doesn't move um do I I don't
even know what I do here I think I leave
the tension he's gonna try and punish me
for buzzer King but that's life wait
this is just a bad London for black cuz
I like bishops stuck
well I'll move back and then I'll just
try and treat this like I don't know
what this is it's like a very slow setup
this is playable
maybe ninety-seven next do this
the biggest issue is time you can place
you for
I'm not trapping anything but at least
I'm getting space he's gonna play e4
yeah I guess I can take and trade more
and then Queen d5 will trade more and if
it's going into an endgame then maybe
time isn't the biggest issue
okay well trade even more Wow maybe I
should have taken first I don't know
there's some small weakness it's play
rook d5 just want to play f5
let's take and then I guess I can take
and then this is tricky this is very
tricky there there there okay I'm gonna
put the King on these seven put the work
on g8 and then if he it's not if he
defends a g5 I defend my H pawn and
maybe it's okay
Wow what's going on here
oh I'm just losing a pond no wait a
minute there there okay I have to go for
counterplay he's not giving me
counterplay
okay there this is bad this is really
really really bad
I'm going to be down like two pawns
you
and I'm long time yeah poor choices
let's played this preventing rook c7
preparing Ricci AIDS
what to do
at least my rukns somehow get active and
he doesn't have a past fun on the
kingside yet but I have a bad feeling my
streak is gonna go away after this game
at the time situation like I need a
miracle wait once um that's a fair move
like what to do okay now I have some
trick now I have some trick I don't know
if it's gonna work but there is a trick
and I might survive this actually I
think I am surviving this
he can't moves to the F file and then
now I just keep checking the King this
is so funny this is just a draw
the King has nowhere to hide and 29
seconds is plenty of time Wow okay I
actually saw that idea earlier I just
didn't want to say anything like on on
stream just in case he was watching but
of course like he should not take f7 you
had to be a bit more careful I'm just
gonna copy and paste all of B on the
mask comments to look at later cuz I'm
not gonna remember everything he's
saying beyond the mask okay that was
nice was a feel good game or feel good
ending
I did lose my winning streak but I kept
up the no law streak okay let's continue
83 points yeah that's why you should
never resign because likes tell me
tricks especially when you have a rook
chess is tricky for anyone watch
Kru 64 last night's it was incredible he
still made it his opponents like three
times in completely winning positions
one of them was me such a nice gift
okay the slide I think is supposed to be
fun for whites but I sort of forget the
theory if there is any theory but this
looks Pleasant like I take I played
Bishop d3 he has to play g6 and my
pieces come into play pretty normally
Jerry and thirty-third okay so maybe
there's an outside chance I'll play him
a bit later you please 97 okay well
Castle just have to play quick let's do
that whoa I just missed a cool tactic I
could have played before and went up on
or win uh when a piece trapped is Bishop
that's kind of sad I'm gonna try and
make it happen I know somehow prepared
before like play a3 brocade to be for
like pure hope chest
who is crew 64 crew 64 is another
xtreamer
who loves talking about me and loves
playing me and overall like an
entertaining entertaining streamer I
didn't think I would I would actually go
for this plan but is it working no it's
not working he yes Bishop d6 if he wants
yeah that was probably not the best
thing to go for
your opponent does what you are supposed
to do what does that even mean my
position is not back right here because
my C pawns backwards before is not a
great plan but okay his D pawns isolated
so we each have kind of our own Pauling
weakness if I take I guess I could take
I take with Bishop stick with Knights
it's a bit more imbalance now now like
his Queen and rook battery are pointless
he's gonna bring the knight to the
square which is kind of annoying let's
play rope t1 challenge the D file
and then double up yeah it's a weird
position better than balance I like my
chances though I have the D file I've
Queen D for coming
that's pause a bit weak he can't play b5
f-4s a resource in the position looks
Pleasant there's a lot of issues for
black and he kind of has to worry about
I four is really tempting i for knight
c6 Queen f6 wait now III is hanging in
some lines I'm just gonna play b5 first
preventing knight c6 and s4 like
practically traps and Knights the only
feasible square would be 93 and then I
went at least upon and meanwhile he
stuck like the knight can't really move
and his Queen and rook are tied down to
the night as King doesn't want to move
back to g7 so yeah this is looking very
pleasant like what to do for black
he plays h4 free pawn back I might just
like play some more waiting loose just
to like torture him more
well f6 is another maybe another mistake
because it allows this and then Bishop
takes c4 that's nice
I'll play rook f8 movie and then Queen
d5 with the massive pin oh he wants to
take let's defend this is just over he
can move his King but the knight would
still be pinned
okay back to tournaments that was nice
something went wrong very quickly
therefore black the position was
unpleasant for white but he kind of lost
his thread I think he should have kept
the C file open the he shouldn't play
Knight c4 so still a healthy lead look
forward in the standings where his chest
network 34th place was working
everything trying to catch up okay we're
playing tejas something Jane let's
suppose work again I'll take opening
recommendations just give me some
recommendations in e4 OS candy okay
let's play a scandi this line it should
be five check I was looking at this
other day and I forget what my
conclusions were f3 I guess f3 and then
Bishop c8 is that how it goes well now I
do this wait I'm trying to remember
there's some some idea that white does
maybe it's just white gives back Papon
but that has a reasonable position like
92 and d4 but I know I went over this in
a future stream and there is some idea
that I remember being cool
maybe it was to play c4 at some points
like I take on I actually I don't know
my memory is failing me right now so if
I take on d5 you can take with pawn so
okay let's do some different plan maybe
start with this if he retreats the
bishop I have 94 and the whole plan is
to get c4 and kick the night away looks
nice
Portuguese gambits yeah I sometimes play
this from the backside it's not a bad
opening but now there's already pressure
on black because if the knight moves
here there's c5 possibilities maybe it's
still okay for black but it looks iffy
why aren't you looking at the chat I
mean it's hard to look at the chat and
play at the same time let me go back do
I miss anything important army is
stalling run down by the enemy forces
okay umm wait once I'll can play F five
against one
efore that's like the worst possible
moving is efore okay we'll take B for f5
the drunken touch I like it Bishop g5
whoa it's gonna be sharp I could play a
three do I do here Queenie want maybe No
I initiate the attack start with Queen
d2 light he wants to play knight c6 so
okay wait
I'm just gonna keep it simple I'll trade
play Bishop III and maybe at some point
play d5 but d5 my bishops undefended
there's another idea to play Bishop a4
and then a 3 and this Knights kind of
stuck I guess he is 93 ok we're not
going to let him open the H file if you
play as h3 I play g3 and h-bonds funny
you're like I'll play h2 I play King h1
and my king is relatively safe or in
this case king h2
this pawn is actually kind of a shield
for the king but he wants to break
through let's play a three
you
okay I have to watch out for time Oh
what do I do
g5 I guess
it's a weird position I guess I want a
pawn storm like b5 coming
play the Grob maybe
I only have time for like one more game
well I hung up on
now I have a file I think the loss of
the pawn is worth the opening of the
file especially in a position like this
maybe I'll even give up like all my
queenside pawns I'll have more open
files
yeah like Bishop here and then c6 b5
breaking through
now b5 is explosive
more explosive than c4 cuz like what's
he doing here like I'm gonna take his
King has nowhere to go except e7 he
plays that but I can take it and like e5
did nothing
oh he wants to do something now but I
think I can get away with this I'm not
sure though because there's some pin
I actually don't know I may have just
blundered a piece but I'm trying to get
my open file action happening whoa okay
I can do this I think he should have
taken on b7 and maybe it wasn't entirely
clear and now it's completely winning so
many files are now open maybe I have
some ladder mates coming in Trixie - and
then queen b1
that's nice queen bee seven rugby two
he's gonna play on we're gonna push up
on okay nice game
it's a weird game weird opening at some
point I have to go back and like take a
closer look at all these openings that
I've been getting into cuz a lot of them
I think I've been out of prep somewhat
early playing Rafael attack okay let's
play a weird opening shall I play a five
let's play a five just for the fans wait
I beserk Stu and I'm playing f5 oh my
gosh okay at least he doesn't didn't
take so it's somewhat uh somewhat
playable what's what's the theory here
is their theory I could play d5 I guess
you look like you're in a kitchen I'm
actually on the beach it's just an
optical illusion
oh yeah we're playing some like what is
this called like a mirrored but like
check Benoni it's like one of these
weird structures this resembles a French
structure let's play h5 and just close
everything down this is gonna be a fun
game this game is not going to finish
before the tournament officially
finishes it's going to be very
structure and somehow I have to win it
with the time deficits nights are
usually pretty valuable in these
situations so this night will sometime
or someday be a god
maybe someday I'll maneuver like to G
for her let's start with c5 I want to
play c4 wait how do I get to g4 oh
that's probably the best square for the
night let's just keep improving I mean
this could easily be a game like over
100 moves if it stays closed some point
I might have to I mean at some point I
probably want to prepare this before
break and this is a type of situation
like it's already better for black you
wants to find 9 g5 okay let's do I want
to do King g7 if he plays my g5 I take
it with the bishop that would be a
no-brainer but rook here I'm gonna bring
the Knight to g4 now where it's somewhat
more godly oh he doesn't want me to go
there okay let's move with a bishop back
there's some x-ray vision all all of the
strategy here is just dancing around and
waiting for some opportunity we'll see
what happens or maybe I just like play
50 moves or I have to avoid the 50 move
rule I forget when the last pawn push
was I have to avoid 15 move rule I don't
even know what I'm doing what what am i
doing okay he's moving back and forth
I'm just making moves to give myself
time to think
um how am I breaking through
okay let's double up and then play
before or maybe even triple up I'll put
the night here oh I tried to make him
think he didn't want to think there
where does my I might want to go wait no
wait what
how was other draw did I repeat no was
it fifty move rule
I didn't think I repeated that oh maybe
I did
no I did
no wait did I it's a repetition
oh man oh I wanted to have like a 200
move game that's so sad when would 50
mover will be
wait a minute
mooove 15 oh we were approaching 50 move
rule
really we had this pawn structure on
move 15 Wow
so we committed the pawns really early
well thank you for the compliment from
pH nice traditional play there was a
glitchy pawn on d7 which was actually
removed a long time ago but still
displayed wait what
oh the magnet situation okay well that
was fun go back to the tournaments
interesting so clear first building my
confidence I have to go like right now
so thank you guys for joining me on this
amazing adventure there's a lot of
people streaming cool well I guess we
can we can raid someone this guy's this
guy's pretty cool
maybe we can raid him
we chess master a very strong player a
pretty young player Oh
oh no maybe we can trade them because
he's streaming on YouTube okay never
mind
let's go back let's go to chess Network
he doesn't need my raid but we're gonna
raid him anyway so how does this work
again I'm gonna type in like raid chest
network and then I'm gonna end the
stream thanks everyone for watching
I'll be back probably tomorrow just go
to my website and see the same the
stream schedule adios and goodbye